sadly but you'll know him because he he
was on fox news on other outlets because
he was talking about vaccines that's the
government and how the government wants
to control us
so yesterday he goes hey man uh he's
like
you know i've been following you for a
while and i know you know what i
represent but
you know we don't have to just talk
about fighting i said bro again i'm not
a journalist you want to talk about the
the gun control which i know he's big on
you want to talk about gun control
whatever
bring it on brother like whatever you
want to do
now do i agree with everything that he's
saying no and some of it he's
misinformed i did try to inform him on
it because i think he did the aerial
show and there was like dude you're
spreading misinformation and whatever
and i think for him you know he's a
young man
and he comes from arkansas he comes from
the country and you know guns are
everything in freedom of speech and
covenant he has his philosophy on the
government how it's controlling us and
all that stuff which is fine
um you know he's talking about i was
asking about gun control because he's
big on second amendment and they're
taking he said you know i do think
government is involved with these school
shootings that's why i press back away i
don't think the government's killing
fourth graders and then he goes no i
don't mean it like that
and he was saying that the government i
think is aware of him could do more to
stop him and they're just not because it
pat it helps them pass the gun laws yeah
i take that a lot from the conspiracy
guys that's all that's going to take our
ar-15s yeah i'm like that's not response
i'm not going to debate him on that but
i just told him and he was like like
look how long it took in that shooting
texas recently with the fourth graders
and he goes and it was a transgender guy
and in my head i'm like well no no no so
then once he got finished saying his
part i go i get with like the
misinformation i go just so you know and
i and it's true like i fell into the
same kind of weird space because well
because you're hearing this stuff well
not only here because social media
there's no
journalists like you know what i'm
saying like there's more there's no
change
yeah there's no there's no sensibility
there's no sensor so anybody can say
anything so when that shooter was going
on they found pictures that uh looked
just like him uh a man in a dress and
like oh it's a transgender shooter right
because obviously then the left's not
gonna run with the narrative all that
stuff right and that came out and people
were saying to me that like yo this
transgender shop this girl i was like
holy [ __ ]
not that i gave it
it was here who did it
but that went viral on the internet the
actual transgender person
in that dress goes whoa this is me i
agree i look similar i did not shoot up
to school please stop spraying the room
yeah but if you're bryce and he you know
he's on social media a lot of he looks
at that but then if you don't look into
it further you're gonna think that so
it is meant some misinformation at the
same time he's also in a current
culture where a younger man who's
getting it from social media and there's
no
regulatory
kind of commission to go no no that's
fake news or we can't confirm this don't
don't spread that so he was like oh it's
transgender we'll know and i said also
with the shooting how long it took i'm
with you that drove me nuts you know i
have a kid who's going into first grade
i have a two-year-old and i told him i
said they're they're in a cop in this
world who could stop me from entering
that school they have to shoot me in the
back like there's not a chance he goes
yeah brother that's right i go but
i talked to a cop my father-in-law was
caught for 30 years when he talked to a
cop i said this is what helps me get
perspective when you talk to a cop now
did they make mistakes one hundred
percent trauma a small town had no clue
how to deal with this shooting this
active shooter and there's certain
things they could have done to prevent
more less deaths but i said the reason
why he was in there so long
and he had us come back and you're like
i don't know if you like this or agree
with it but i said you got to realize it
went from active shooter to hostage
situation and then bryce goes you you
guys keep saying that
but there's gunshots ringing off of him
killing those kids that should go from a
host situation to him murdering kids
they should enter the building and he
goes when those cops sign up
as cops they say hey we're gonna with
our lives we're going to defend these
kids and they did not do that and i said
fear point yeah but that's the thing i'm
really quiet about this stuff and here's
why because you don't i'm not a cop
i wasn't there i sure as [ __ ] know
nothing about a hostage situation or an
active student i'm not trained for that
i don't know all the little variables on
the ground
so for me i don't know one thing talking
to multiple cops yeah he said it was not
handled correctly i'm sure now sure as
far as not rushing in from the bat
that's because they were under an
impression of the hostage situation yeah
but then once we're done two cops once
the two cops shot and wounded
that's a good question yes no you're
right yeah okay so so two cops were shut
down i mean you stopped going in no but
but it does mean that's part of the gig
a lot of them thought they
i i wasn't there so i i i i think
everybody's got these points of view on
this and but here's my thing being
that's why i said to bryce i said
the reason why i'm such a fan of yours
whether i agree with your points or not
i do think so much misinformation on all
accounts left right middle everybody
doesn't know what the [ __ ] happened only
people there know what happened and we
get the reports we're like oh it's easy
for us to come up with judgment when it
comes to price i said the reason why i
like you and i root for you is because
you speak your truth most athletes are
told to shut up and dribble shut up and
fight but you double down and because
it's natural to you you're not doing it
to get clicks or like he's far from that
yeah i said the reason why i like you is
because you speak your truth and you
believe in it whether i agree with it
right or wrong doesn't matter you're
doing what you think is right in your
heart and that's why i [ __ ] with you man
now what he said do i agree with all of
it no of course not but a lot of it i
can see how people come to that
conclusion but there are a lot of see
the [ __ ] problem with misinformation
is this you got good people like this
kid who is simply getting the wrong
information and then getting passionate
about it and then
galvanizing a community or joining a
community and adding his voice to the
mix okay